- [Instructor] We are asked to calculate
the number of moles in a 1.52
kilogram sample of glucose.
So like always, pause this video
and try to figure this out on your own
and this periodic table of
elements will prove useful.
All right, now if we're
trying to figure out
the number of moles,
remember, mole is really,
you can view it as a
quantity of something.
If I said a dozen of something,
you'd say oh, that's 12 of that thing.
If I say a mole of something,
I'm saying that's Avogadro's
number of that thing.
And so we have a 1.52 kilograms sample
of our molecule in question, of glucose
so if we can figure out the mass per mole,
or another way to think about it,
the molar mass of glucose,
well then we just divide
the mass of our sample
by the mass per mole
and we'll know how many moles we have.
So what is the molar mass of glucose?
Well to figure that out, and that's why
this periodic table of elements is useful,
we just have to figure out the molar mass
of the constituent elements.
So if we first look at carbon,
carbon, we see from this
periodic table of elements,
has a molar mass of 12.01 grams per mole.
We've talked about it in other videos,
you could view this 12.01
as a relative atomic mass
of a carbon atom,
of as the average atomic
mass of a carbon atom,
or what's useful, and this is where
Avogadro's Number is valuable,
if you have Avogadro's Number of carbons,
it is going to have a mass of 12.01 grams.
So carbon has a molar mass
of 12.01 grams per mole
and now we can think about
hydrogen in the same way.
Hydrogen has a molar mass
of 1.008 grams per mole,
008 grams per mole.
And then last but not
least, we have oxygen here.
Oxygen, we can see from our
periodic table of elements,
it has a molar mass of
16.00 grams per mole.
And so now we have all
the information we need
from our periodic table of elements.
So the molar mass of
glucose is going to be six
times the molar mass of carbon
plus 12 times the molar mass of hydrogen
plus six times the molar mass of oxygen.
So it's going to be six
times 12.01 grams per mole
plus 12 times 1.008 grams per mole
plus every molecule of
glucose has six oxygen
plus six times 16.00 grams per mole.
Six times 12.01
plus 12 times 1.008
plus six times 16
is equal to, and if we're thinking
about significant figures here,
the molar mass of hydrogen
goes to the thousandths place
but we only go to the
hundredths for carbon
and for oxygen, we're adding
all of these up together
so it's going to be 180.
I can only go to the hundredths place
for significant figures, so 180.16.
So that's equal to 180.16 grams per mole.
And we could say grams of glucose, C6H12O6
per mole of glucose, C6H12O6
and then we can use this 1.52 kilograms
to figure out how many moles we have.
So if we start off with
1.52 kilograms of glucose,
so that's C6H12O6,
well first we can convert it to grams
'cause here, our molar mass
is given in terms of grams,
so times, we're going to want kilograms
in the denominator and
grams in the numerator,
so how many grams are there per kilograms?
Well, we have 1,000 grams
for every one kilogram.
So when you multiply these two out,
this is going to give
you the number of grams
we have of glucose which would be 1,520
and if you have your
mass in terms of grams,
you can then divide by your molar mass
or you can view it as multiplying
it by the moles per gram.
So for every one mole of glucose, C6H12O6,
we have 180.16 grams of glucose,
C6H12O6,
and this is going to get us,
we get 1.52 times 1,000 is equal to,
this is the number of
grams of glucose we have,
and then we're going to divide by 180.16,
divide by 180.16,
gives us this number,
and let's see, if we
see significant figures,
we have three significant figures here,
we have five here so we wanna round it
to three significant figures,
so it will be 8.44 moles of glucose.
So our kilograms cancel with our kilograms
and then our grams of glucose
cancel with our grams of glucose
and we are left with
8.44 moles of glucose,
moles of C6H12O6.
And we are done.